so herzlich Willkommen zu WWM im
Fernsehen heißt es Wer wird Millionär
bei uns wer weiß
mehr unser heutiges Thema ist K1 und wir
haben einen der sich damit richtig gut
auskennt und es ist niemand anderes als
K1 okay wollen wir mal gucken ob du
wirklich Ahnung von dir hast wir haben
über michind quizfagen über dich
und ja wenn du alle beantworten kannst
hast du gewonnen aber was habe ich denn
dann
gewonnen muss ich mir noch mal überlegen
vol Spiel aber den Fall hatten wir noch
nicht kaffeebohen hier gewonnen genau ka
z.B pass auf also jetzt mal wirklich
Konzentration du musst dich wirklich
konzentrieren weil wir wissen zwar nicht
um was es geht aber es geht um was okay
also kenes allein zu Haus dein
Debütalbum enthält wie viel Titel A 19
Titel B 20 Titel C 21 Titel oder D 22
Titel okay es jetzt schwierig weil gibt
Standard und da gibt's eine Premium die
normale die die Standard die Standard
dann sag ich 16 und dann sind deine
ganzen Antworten falsch ach so
stimmt die Premium war das die Premium
Premium Premium aber ich würde bei der
Premium jetzt sagen
21 würdest du also C21 einlocken wen es
C war dann würde ich sagen ja C okay er
logt C21 ein das ist richtig richtig
sensationell fantastisch 0 schon aus so
pass auf du hast du weißt in dem Film
zeiten ändern dich spielst du eine Szene
wo du mit Bushido auf der Bühne stehst
und ein Text schib
genau reicht mir nicht deine Hand und
ihr redet darüber ähm äh wie wie was
dafür textzahen drin reicht mir nicht
deine bestimm schon die Antwort we
überlegst du dir gerade so eine andere
Frage und du sagst folgenden Satz ja ja
klar und jetzt wie geht dieser Satz
weiter ja ja klar du hast einen an der
Waffe ist a ja ja klar du startest so äh
ist äh die B ja ja klar du tickst nicht
ganz richtig wer die C und die D ist ja
ja klar du fängst so an was sagst du in
dieser
Szene du fängst so an ja ja klar du
fängst so an ja das willst du einlog du
bist ganz sicher ich würde es so sagen
okay D ein und das ist richtig
fantastisch sich freut mehr als ich
fantastisch so jetzt wollen wir mal
gucken jetzt woll mal gucken jetzt
wird's
schwierig gan andere Sachen ja Ja Nein
neinin steht da natürlich richtig pass
auf jetzt konzent Waschmittel oder SAS
settel von Einkaufen
jetzt bei der Google fotosuche wenn man
nach K1 sucht welches Foto erscheint
zuerst ein Foto auf dem du a mit Gina
Lisa zu sehen bist B mit
Mandy C mit Bushido oder D mit deinem
Friseur ich würde sagen a Gina Lisa ich
weiß nicht warum aber du würdest a
einlocken ja du möchtest kein Joker
nutzen wir haben noch Joker gerade fällt
gerade ein
F ich ein okay ich Lock
ein und das ist leider
falsch aber aktualisiert sich Tag neu es
ist es ist es wird aber noch eine ganze
Weile es ist d mit deinem Friseur meinem
Friseur ja wirklich
jetzt und mach rum K sofort sofort
checken pass auf vi pass auf Leute ich
habe gedacht du hast kein Internet doch
doch ich habe Internet einfach weil die
Kamera an ist nein ich habe Internet ich
hat Seite einfach gespeichert Screenshot
Quatsch also ich habe kein Internet hier
sehr so K1
so jetzt gehen wir zur
Bildersuche und meine Damen und Herren
sie sehen es das erste Foto hier noch
ist es grau und was ist da ja als hast
aber Fehler gemacht wieso habe ich ein
Fehler gemacht weil es mein kleiner
Bruder ist dein kleiner Bruder ist dein
Friseur ja ja aber das stimmt ja
trotzdem ja nee me Friseur schneide mir
halt gerade die Haare nee das GT nicht
weil hättest Du gesagt weil weil ich
habe was ganz anderes gedacht ich habe
mein Friseur gedacht und ich wusste hät
gesagt hät du gesagt ein Bild von meinem
Bruder dann hätte ich mir das nämlich
noch mal überlegt und dann hätte ich
nämlich gewonnen gut jetzt wird wirklich
spannend bei W Millionär gab's das ja
noch nie eine nein das ist jetzt meine
aufreg die Fragen gehen aus bei gibt das
E nicht bei WWM kann das durchaus
passieren du hast ja heute in der
Lindenstraße eine Rolle übernommen und
da gab es mehrere Schauspieler in dieser
Szene also sprechende Rollen m wie viel
waren das waren das
A3
B4 C5 oder
D6
se du logst sechs ein ja das ist richtig
weil die beiden waren Kompassen ja
richtig also er die kerin hat gesprochen
dadurch dass sie kurz was gesagt hat mit
dem getränkanbieten Z ein sprecherding
wir beide haben geredet 1 2 3 4 5
6 okay sagt einfachon eel hab wir loggen
mal ein und er hat jetzt erklärt und er
hat recht herzlich Glückwunsch meine D
das das erste Mal K1 gewinnt bei WBM was
wissen wir nicht aber gewonnen ist ja
auch schön ne herzlichen Glückwunsch
danke und wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr WWM
sehen wollt unsere Premiere mit
Silbermond die sich nicht ganz so gut
geschlagen haben wie K1 und ähnlich
bescheuert das chaoskochen auch eine
Premiere nämlich die mit Bano sehr
lustig also bis dann bleib
dran